okay crisis Halloween my little toy
story kids
thanks to Kylie Jenner things are about
to get real freaking cute around here on
Monday Kylie took to her Instagram story
to show off her pups rocking their toy
story Halloween costumes yep that's
Norman aka
Normie Bambi and Sophia bringing all
those festive four-legged fur baby feels
dressed as the leaf characters from the
hit Disney flick a little woody smile
for the camera
I mean just look at that checkered shirt
and matching bandanna and do not even
get me started on the mini cowboy hat
who else's day just got ten times better
just me okay but wait it's about to get
even cuter with this itty bitty Little
Bo Peep honestly you guys I'm dying over
here this is exactly the kind of news
the world needs right now am i right
three Jenner playing together in Disney
costumes I literally can't
but Kylie's next level dog mom's skills
aren't the only thing that has people
talking
on Monday just a week after the Keeping
Up with the Kardashians star confirmed
that she and Travis Scott were taking
time apart the rapper posted two videos
to his insta story featuring their baby
girl stormy dancing to his music and it
sounds like Kylie may be in the
background and while we can't see Kylie
it definitely sounds like her let's run
that back one more time shall we
is that a tease for me earlier this
month
ét learned that Kylie and Travis decided
to take a break after more than two
years of dating a source at the time
told ET the two hadn't been together as
a couple for roughly a month but our
unquote good terms
Kylie echoed that sentiment telling our
fans on Twitter quote Travis and I are
on great terms and our main focus right
now is stormy our friendship and our
daughter is priority people say things
all the time and some things I just
think feel like responding to so I just
felt like responding to that one now a
source tells ET quote Kylie has exactly
what she's always wanted a child and to
be a young mother although she hopes
things with Travis do work out she knows
she'll be okay if they don't with all
those cute puppies running around in
costumes how could things not be okay
yeah I'm still on that of course ET will
be right here to keep you up with all
things Kardashians Jenner's so make sure
to keep it locked right here until next
time I'm Hallie Stephens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]